this past Friday Donald Trump took over
the president's official Twitter handle
@potus and within minutes there was
controversy of course probably the first
background image they chose a crowd
waving American flags was actually a
picture from President Obama's
inauguration in 2009 people started
pointing this out so Trump's team
scrambled to replace the picture with
one of their own their replacement photo
was a little weird take a look they put
this one up then they changed it to this
to try and make it better that so they
replace that one with this photo right
here that wasn't so good so they quickly
change it to this one right here people
got really bummed out about that one so
they took that down and put up this
photo right here that's just an ad for
the new xxx return of xander cage that
looked like a mistake so finally they
just went with this one and everyone's
happy now
sandir page before I went to show
business that was my name Andy sander
cage sake that doesn't that's not good
for comedy Conan O'Brien that's good for
comedy
you